as I said we have each weird hold on
just a second I got a text oh no this is
terrible news what I got an alert here
that says a famous celebrity just died
who says Andy Richter Conan I'm pretty
sure I didn't die because I'm right here
Andy I want to believe you but look okay
now I'm getting an alert from CNN check
this out
nation mourns loss of funny man Andy
Richter good god this is been terrible
since obviously one of those internet
hoaxes this happens all the time I mean
last night our last week the internet
was saying Axl Rose and that Dog
Whisperer guy died oh my God look it's
TMZ check that out kick kick sit that's
pretty funny I've never been on TMZ yeah
pretty cool yeah I think it's another
one call in The Drudge Report look at
that look oh that's nice that's a little
marker they're always hard man and my
feet look good yeah all right how does
it say I died well they're not saying
but BuzzFeed does have the seven ways
you didn't die check it out
- Kaizen this this news has already
spread to North Korea and it seems like
they're taking it really hard check this
out video out
[Applause]
celebrities are already tweeting about
Andy dying look at this it says right
here check it out at Billy Bush says he
was a big inspiration to me and whatever
it is I do Kim Kardashian's Here Kim
Kardashian tweeted I only use
fashionista nail tips also hashtag r.i.p
andy oh look the Pope the Pope I had
about any dying he said I checked and he
didn't go up you know Conan I really
don't know there about about to hear a
moving tribute song for you performed by
the one and only Josh Michael Gro bleh
he was a contraband but with a twinkle
in his step but like the shamrock shake
on March 18
he's gone you were a master
telephone scotch in a backpack a smile
see other side kick - ha
[Music]
I'm gonna miss me yeah Andy I have to
say I honestly don't know what I'm gonna
do without you hey Conan I saw your text
and I got here as fast as I could
[Applause]
cohdon I'm sorry for your loss but I'm
really looking forward to working here
I'm not even dead five minutes you're
already replacing me Andy I replaced you
instantly good one boss you're the best
Fred thank you thanks for the generous
salary offer double one Andy ever dreamt
two times nothing still nothing
alright lizardom and Fred and I will be
right back with Rosaria Dyson
you